whoa Hank green Charlie McDonnell have
you been watching my week of madness I
have charlie well all of your opinions
got do more to it
365 days charlie oh is that just it then
just I have to do this forever now I
think that that would actually be a
horrible idea I think an important part
of it is my personal sanity as relieving
is this has been to do as a thing just
to be like making stuff all the time it
is also just very hard yeah I remember
back in the day when John and I were
making videos every day like you ready
to really sort of force stuff sometimes
yeah I'm gonna do a song today it's
about purple it's a mix of it can like
be really hard to just sit down one day
and think I have no ideas today until
then it's also a case if it can be like
on those days where you just have to
fall something out of you you could just
come up with something you would not and
I think you're really good like
surprisingly good that's my favorite old
vlog where those videos were the ones
where I just sat down and I had no idea
what the hell is going to do I was like
I'm gonna put something on my head and
then that become a thing I want there to
be more Charlie content but I also
really like that you put a lot of effort
into each video this has proved that you
should do both like and you shouldn't
feel bad about having a video where you
just talk about something that you think
is interesting I was just forgetting
about how nice blocking is just to be
like here's an opinion I have for a
while that's not the kind of content I
would want to make all the time but it
is something I've found that I you know
remembered that I enjoy thanks Hank for
your opinion why firstly I just want to
say thank you everyone for bothering to
watch me during this little crisis
period of mine at the start this week I
think I was noticeably stressed out
about the idea of making a video every
single day and worrying about if that
was even a thing I could do but now it's
become a thing that just feels right to
me it just feels natural but I just want
to be making as much content as I
possibly can in my kind of creative life
I've always thought that you can have
one of two things you can have quality
over quantity or quantity over quality
and I've always felt that I like to sit
on the side of quality you know I want
to be making the best stuff that I
possibly can and I don't mind the idea
that I won't be making as much stuff as
a result of that but the revelation that
and this week which has sort of been
like a really crazy realization for me
is that you can have both quality and
quantity and by that I don't mean that I
think it's possible for people to make
really high quality stuff all the time
but I mean that now I don't think it
would be a problem for me to be trying
to make the best quality stuff that I
can you know stuff that I put weeks of
planning into but to make that stuff
well also as often as I can be making
videos like this video blogs where I
just sit and talk to you for a while
about things that are on my mind well
that's what happened Charlie made more
videos for a week and now he wants to
make more videos generally so yay
formats I feel okay now bye you've just
had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool are you happy to
talk about earlier today when I walked
into your office and you were not
wearing any trousers I had flipped it
and I had a call and I the pants were my
first priority okay and he's very quiet
mm-hmm you'll do it was I that's one
thing I mean I was wearing underpants
yes